un moment historique des canadiens de
partout au pays
venu déclarer leur attachement au québec
un drapeau géant devenu symbole de ce
rassemblement à montréal et celle de ses
amis sont derrière cette initiative de
dernière minute
ils étaient huit entassés dans une mini
fourgonnette avec l'immense drapeau
ils sont partis de windsor en ontario
kenneth compteur était le chauffeur un
groupe
épuisé mais déterminés à lancer un
message d'unité aux québécois les normes
drapeau a rapidement attiré l'attention
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
réunies sur la place du cade et honda
barbie ken qu'avec 30 accords fois gaza
dans la foule jose buisson et ses amis
des étudiants franco-ontarien venue de
sudbury en ontario et vous l'êtes
exprimé les préoccupations des
francophones hors québec
ben il y en a plusieurs qu'il ne sachant
pas qu'il y avait des francophones hors
québec c'est une chance de l'antirouille
on existe aussi là que nous on est
content justement cette séparation
25 ans plus tard le résultat du vote au
référendum québécois la réconforte
encore jeu bien content qu'ils ne se
sont pas séparés je pense qu'il y aura
une grosse perte nous surtout remonter
on se rassure on a davantage de services
en français ça nous rassure de ce côté
là
au niveau de notre culture notre
affirmation l'instant de n'être langue
aussi que notre compteur aussi aiment se
remémorer le rassemblement il aime
penser que sa fille de 10 ans est fier
de ce qu'il a fait bah oui et non pour
beaucoup de canadiens le référendum de
1995 demeure au moment qu'ils espèrent
ne jamais revivre